So let me show you something that,
that same group and
others pushed on a little bit more
recent of handling occlusion.
So the question is, you know,
if, if a thing gets partially occluded,
we have this problem,
because you remember the Eigenface stuff
is, it's capturing the entire image.
As a vector, and
all the pixels all the components
in that vector are created equal.
So if some of them are sort
of being blocked or
obscured, it's not going to
be able to explain that data,
it's not going to be able to track, give
you very high probability at that area.
But it turns out you can,
you can address that if you think
about the following, all right.
By the way that's Greg Dudack
a while back, hi Greg.
Picture there.
When I reproduce an image, so let's
suppose I've, I've tracked this thing,
I've completed my Eigenbasis and
now I, I'm trying to find my best one,
and I do.
I can now say of all those pixels,
which ones am I reconstructing well?
The ones that I'm reconstructing well,
those are the ones that I have
a lot more confidence in.
So let me create a weight mask that
says, you know, those pixels are fine,
but anywhere that I find something that
I can't reconstruct well, I'm going to
highlight those pixels as ones that
I'm not going to pay attention to.
By the way,
the reason I'm saying highlighted is on
the video I'm about to show you,
for whatever reason, they have,
sort of, bad pixels as being bright.
So you can think of them
as being highlighted for
not counting as much in the current or
the next iteration.
So what you're going to see
here in this video again is, so
here's the, Greg's face.
That' s going to be tracked.
And this is the, sort of,
the location of what they're doing.
But what you'll see here is,
there'll be this black image, and
then, all of a sudden, you'll see
his hand swipe up across his face.
Now, of course his hand is not easily
reproduced with the face Eigenbasis.
So you're going to see that light up,
and that's it saying okay,
the weight of those
pixels should be reduced.
So let's see if this works.
There it goes, its playing, okay.
Same thing we see before.
You see his Eigenvectors changing
on the bottom as he rotates in
and out of the plane.
Whoops!
There was his hand.
Did you miss that?
Let go back again.
Now get ready, in a minute, he's
going to swipe his hand over his face,
there, there it goes.
Did you see that?
You can play it backwards,
as his hand came up,
the weights got brighter where the hand
was, saying ignore this, this place.
And now it tracks him for awhile.
He's smiling, he's getting large,
and moving around and
you can see it's doing
a good job tracking.
You can see the difference between
how well it can be reconstructed.
And the reason it can handle things
like this is remember the state
that's it's tracking is position
translation rotation scale.
So you can normalize it back to
the original sort of canonical view and
explain that view from the Eigenbasis.
All right, so
that's some pretty cool tracking work.